à paris la presse est elle en marche on
sait depuis hier que la commission
nationale de la communication et des
libertés sera remplacé dans quelques
mois par une nouvelle instance le csa le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel ce
matin premier acte avec la formation
d'un groupe d'experts chargé d'élaborer
le projet de loi qui sera soumis au
parlement à la session d'automne dans
quelques mois
retrouve quelques têtes bien connues
olivier lerner pire des groupes 69 ans
célèbre producteur de cinq colonnes à la
une
ancien pdg d'antenne de françoise giroud
journaliste ancien secrétaire d'état à
la condition féminine et fuit de la
culture claude santelli 65 ans auteur
producteur ancien président de la
société des auteurs et compositeurs
dramatiques
danièle delorme comédienne productrice
membre du conseil économique et social
et trois juristes pierre avril jean
gicquel et jean révéreault au total cet
expert entourent deux ministres cette
forte tête incontestable que la création
en france ne redémarre pas que la
création est étouffée que les programmes
ils sont souvent médiocre que la logique
commerciale si complètement substituer à
la logique coeur
artistique du domaine participe à la
logique du spectateur spectateurs
curieux c'est vrai dans le public comme
dans le privé
alors il faut voyager contre ça mais ça
n'est pas notre tâche pour l'instant si
jamais le gouvernement chances de
tendance on a en aura pas besoin de te
refaire et dehors vers une certaine
autorité sera primé inscrit dans la
constitution c'est le voeu du président
ben ali que je pense que si elle veut
que ça fait raisonnable et sage mais
c'est peu de chose qu'on mène à la
constitution je ne sais pas une refonte
c'est pas façon pression au travail fait
valoir les notaires
réflexion consultation rédaction une
mission à trois volets pour ses
consultants qui quoi qu'il arrive vont
signer l'arrêt de mort de la cncl
enfin et obtient enfin la solution
indiscutable
autorités impuissantes
cncl éclaboussé pour inspirer ce
sentiment qu'on appelle le respect les
metteurs en scène du conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel ça parfaitement à quoi
s'en tenir